Nếu khi giá dầu thủng nóng, mục tâm đô lắm Mỹ mục thủng gió xúc độc lâu tháng,
nhiều quốc gia đứa mặt mấy cố ngán lượng tích tế nghiêm đồng.
Bây giờ, có người lại phố thủ dầu, đếp lại.
Hãy nhìn vào những con số này.
Năm này không thể tờ, thay giới tư hủ kỹ lục 1,5 mục phép tâm trưởng dầu mũ này.
Trong một khập kỹ qua, 1 năm đu cầu dầu tài cầu lại tạm một phần đam.
Tên cầu đánh tư tố khoảng 3 ngày 1,5 tế đô lắm Mỹ mỗi năm, đêm 1 dầu thổ.
Có số này tự đường với khoảng 1,5 tế 3 phần trạm trình về phố Mỹ,
kết thuy giá ngành lần chỉ ra 1 li dầu khi có người phố thủ và dầu mò như sọng.
Đi giờ thích nhất, dầu lệ nhìn lếu dễ vật chuyện.
Thưa bà Sement at Cross, dầu ở dạng lắm, giế đu qua đường ốc và dễ bơm vào đúng cơm.
Ngày đặc tính này, dầu mò chắc thành những lựa lý tự chơi dầu thông đến đại.
Mà phải đặc phần trạm dầu được tích dễ thành đe Xen, dầu công nghệ bản như lựa, mấy bài.
Mà mì mốt phần trạm trạm trạm xanh và nắp ta, quý lựa dụng trong nha tốt nghiệp để hình như bản dẫn.
Mà yếu phần trạm dầu được tích dễ thành phùa ory, dụng cho tao biển và một số như mấy đỉnh.
Nhi giờ thích hai, dầu hiến dĩnh trong nhiều sản phẩm khác.
Dầu mò không chỉ là như lựa, mặc có hiến dĩnh trong hạn ngang sản phẩm trong đề số.
Hoang 2 mì só phần trạm lựa dầu con người tưu thủ đi vào để sản xuất hiện dựa, phân bóng, khu, sải tổng học, dứa mòi em như được.
Lìa số bà, hát tân khóm lâu đã được xe dính xùa quần dựa mò.
Trong không một thế kiế hoa, hát tân mức lựa tàn cầu ở đường ống nhà máy lập dầu ở ý phương tiền vận tải.
Lếu được xe dính quần dựa mò, đơn vịt thì thấy hoàn trạm sẽ đứa khó và tụi kếm.
Lìa thích tựa, hếu các lựa trọng thể thấy thả thịt.
Lìa là mật lộn lựa.
Theo bà Sementar Cross, xếp theo trong lựa, sản phẩm liệt dẻ n cứu nựa rất khoảng 4 mũi lập viện đại.
Quảng 3,5 kg em sang có thể giúp xe trẻ tâm 5.8 mũi kêu mẹ.
Trong khi bình nặng tương đưa, chỉ giúp xe đề gì kiếc xoạn 3 mũi kêu mẹ.
Mời ra, nhiều ngàn công nghiệp như thép xí mang thủy tình,
cân giết lộ bùng ngàn tức một ngàn bú cập đưa xe.
Mước như khi ngay trù yêu tạo ra mạnh cách lúc như nếu.
Mì vậy, các lính vật như hàn khó bần tải biển và xe tải đần dài rất khó rời bỏ dùa ngàn.
Gính chứng cho thấy, theo kịch bản của EA,
sẽ đến kịp khoảng 4 mũi phần tâm dân số sau 2 không bao lắm,
như câu yâu vẫn tăng lên khoảng 1,8 mũi bà tiêu thủ mũ kể,
bỏ năm hình a ngàn cũng trận nằm mới.
Theo kết thuy ra, nếu xung đột kế giải tất tất tư,
ý dầu của thế lệ 1,5 mũi lâu là mỹ mũ thông,
sẽ ghi ra 1 cuộc sửa phá kinh tế.